*Screams* What the fucking Goddamn it?! Oh my god.
That scared the bajesums out of me.
Oh, fuck dude. Ah eh ugghh...
*distressed Mark face*
HI!
Hi guys. HELLO, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now, I didn't expect to be starting this off so soon.
Something decided to pay me a visit and my ship is now extremely damaged.
I don't know what the fuck that was.
Oh...
You?! No! No way?! I don't believe that for a second.
Okay, but hi. Welcome back to Subnautica. Now, I've been looking forward to this episode
And also I have not been looking forward to this episode and
we are incredibly damaged and I have to go repair that right now.
But all that aside...
*BIG sigh*
We are either-
We are either going to face certain death *giggles* in the depths... Oh! You...
Oh, you! Why are you jus-?
Oh it mesmerized.
Oh that's...
*sudden realization* OH!
I don't know what happened there.
What's happening?!
Who's thumping?!
Oh my god. I don't want to know. You know what, I don't want to know!
OH BOY... I don't want to know. I don't want to know anything.
I don't wanna- want to know what's thumping here.
I don't want to be down here
I don't want to be anywhere!
*nervous laughter*
Okay, but either way
so we are fine obvious-obviously
We are,supposedly fine?
I don't know what the thumpies are but I'm just assuming the ghosts are back so...
We can only assume that they're going to carry down with us, down to the depths of hell and we're going to be totally fine
Down there, with them with us.
So with that being said, we're gonna go down into the Lava Zone no matter what
Like that is definitely happening. But first before I do that...
Before I do that I have to: One, read some names and put up some lockers
and number two, I have to, uh...
Unfortunately, I think, use a console command for the immediate future because, some people are saying
that the Ghost Leviathan is in the game but I have confirmed that it is not.
But that doesn't mean that you can't spawn it in.
So, to do that, you need to use a console command, and I didn't think I would be using one in another episode here but
unfortunately, I just want to show it to you guys.
And apparently it's *sexy Mark voice* BIG.
Apparently is REALLY BIG
Now, I've never seen it myself, but we're gonna see it together
So I'll be right back once I'm able to show you that.
So I put the lockers over here. Don't mind that they cut into the pipes like that,
I'm sure there not very important. So, we got
IAmAwesomeFoxy: "Mark, I am not sure if you know this
but when you picked up the help signal from the terminal,
you actually picked up the blueprints for the rocket. If you check your inventory when you're reading
Robin Eklund's note, you have six new blueprints, but when you picked up the
help call from the terminal, you had five more blueprints.
Wonder why? Hope you see this message that EXPANDS YOUR KNOWLEDGE."
So, I'm gonna look into that right now because I don't believe that for a second.
Do I?
Can I?
Do I?!
Well it doesn't seem like it, and I don't know what the hell is going on out there.
But I didn't stop by to visit Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise and Marshal so I don't know if that's true
But even thusly, I don't know if I'd be able to escape but
I won't be able to do anything unless I cure the Carar virus that is coursing through my veins
and causing me great problems down here in the reefs.
STOP IT!!!!
Then there's ZiZoo Bob who gave a really, really nice and encouraging message, who said,
"I am don't mind, Markiplier, if you cheated. All I want from you is the good work and not die very much."
And that is so sweet. That is actual legitimately sweet.
'Cause I felt bad about having to use the cheat code to be able to open the doors on the Aurora
But now I feel, I feel a little bit like, my soul has a little weight lifted off of it.
And then there's, uh, xxd3athxnotexx who said, "Mark, legend has it that the Ghost Leviathan is attracted to a
big, yellow submarine and a loud doofus, who screams at everything he sees.
You've. Been. Warned.
AH it's whatever! That's a bunch of hogwash!
I don't believe that for a goddamn second. Nobody can convince me otherwise.
Okay!
*nervously* Let me save. Let me save before I do this. OKAY!
I think the bones of this dead, probably Ghost Leviathan, are good enough for spawning in the
Ghost Leviathan. So, I believe this...
OH FUCKING HELL HI!
Hoooly shiiiit.
Hi...
*giggles of excitement* HOHOHO OHOHO
HI!
Oh, hi. Oh, hi.
Oh, you're nuzzling.
I pissed my pants.
Oh HI! Oh god, stop nuzzling.
Oh, JESUS.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, OH MY-OH MY GOD!!
*stares in awe*
Oh...
Well, that's spooky.
Ugh...
Oh, I don't like that.
Oh my god, it has a mouth *laughs nervously*
Oh hoho...
Okay. Alright!
So, it's not fully implemented yet, but that is fricken terrifying.
It's not...
It-I mean, depending on the- *pff*
I'm not gonna make any assumptions-
ooohhh, hi. Oh god, oh, don't do that to me.
Oh, don't do that to me.
Oh, fuck dude.
*nervous laughter* Ah, just nomming on- *panics*
AH! AAH!
OH FUCK!!!!
I didn't know you could actually hurt me.
I didn't know you could, I-
I thought you were like, you know, not implemented.
OKAY!! He's gonna...ghost into the rocks there!!
Everything's FINNNNNNE!!!!!!!!
Oh god, is he gonna come back for a second pass?
Oh, fuck-
Oh, whoa! Whoa! Whoa! Whooaa!
Whoa! Whoaaa!
Whooooaa! Whooa!
WHOAAAAA!!
Maybe it is attracted to everything that just screams at it.
Hey, you leave Barry alone!
Oh my god.
Oh my GOD.
Okay, so, I've been mesmerized by this thing,
and oh MY GOD.
OH MY GOD!!
Oh, so fucking scary.
Oh, so goddamn scary.
Oh god, I'm about to run out of oxygen.
OKAY! I don't know if it did any damage to Big Box Barry, but-
M'kay, "swim to surface". Yeah, 700m up.
Fuck.
Is this whole thing about to explode?!
Are you almost dead?!
No, you're fine. Okay, you're fine.
You got barely any damage at all.
(check yourself Mark)
Oh, but it sees it out there.
Oh my god.
Foof...
Foof foof.
Foof foof
(he's a dog now)
Foofen Foofenheimer
Oh my god.
Oh, jeez.
It is...
*panics again*
(French Mark?)
Oh ho, HEY! HEY!
HEY!
BACK OFF!
HEY
FUCK YOU
FUCK OFF!!
*sighs*
Oh man, it really wants a piece of me
Okay,
but anyway,
that is the...
that's the Ghost Leviathan.
That's the Ghost Leviathan and yeah, it's flippin' huge!
I mean, uh, I'm amusing that they're gonna put in an eating animation later on.
Fucking goddamn it, stop.
They're gonna put in-
STOP!!
They're gonna put in an eating animation later on in the game, of course
because it's gonna kill ya, but I've also heard that this thing exists
to prevent you from going too far out in the ocean
and you can only imagine what's beyond the reef. (Moana reference? -no, it's not the reef it's beyond the line-)
Because we've been in a relatively safe area in this game,
I say relatively.
But I've said before in an episode,
this planet is flippin' huge!
HUGE!
What enormous monstrosities,
like this one here-
in the bones I'm talking about, not like the ghost but-
What flippin' huge monstrosities exists out there beyond the known universe?
Probably bad ones
Okay! But that's not the main reason we're here.
Ugh, stop staring at me.
We are gonna go down into that Lava Zone.
F- *surprised Markiplier*
Sorry
Doohhh no no no no no UGH!
Aye yayayaya
I need to change out the batteries real bad in this bad boy.
But that was c-cooooool...(!)
I think?
Hope it's okay that I just leave it there.
Ugh
*scared Markiplier*
Jesums.
Flip a dick.
Goddamn it.
Okay
So, we're fine, apparently everything just blew up and that's fine! Whatever!!
*scared again*
AGAIN! Am I gonna die?! Or what?!
wHats ACtuALLy haPpENiNg HEre
Can you tell me!? I'd like to know!
Jesums.
Okay,
but I'm about to die,
I thought it was gonna kill me if it ever attacked me but...
it just left me a little mortally wounded.
So, that's fine and now comes the slow crawl of a journey down,
down,
down...
*darkiplier?* down into the depths of low
So, I'll see you when I get down there
EhzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZ
UUUUUUUUGGGGGGHHHHH
EH HE HEE HEE HEE HEE HEE HEE I HAAATEEE
THAT SSSSSS----
Oh god, I hate it so much.
Eh hee hee hee
Ima brave boy
iMA brAve bOY
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, everybody.
I'm sorry.
I mean to be braver than this but god it's...
okay...
I don't know what that scream was, but I think I remember there being some random screaming
happening inside my brain...
when I get near this tree...
*screams of the dead*
Ehhhhh...
Oh god...
I just
fucking
hate. The. Ocean.
i HaTE tHe OcEAn
So much
I hate it soooo much!
Ahahah I hate it *cries*
Eh, it's okay though.
Ooh, I'm gonna stop being a bitch baby.
Hello.
Welcome to the world.
And I can't help but think that those are eggs,
and if those ARE eggs then...
well, I'm fucked.
But, you know, if they're not then...
Karen: Caution, mild dehydration detected. (Fuck, Karen)
Don't spook me like that...
But if they're not eggs, then I guess that's okay, unless it turns into some giant carnivorous plant,
which I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED IN THIS OCEAN OF MADNESS
with which I find myself in.
*sigh* Boy...
I need the cure.
I need the cure, real-
*Bellows from the depths of hell
*thinking: WHAT THE FUCK*
Well, that's an option.
That music's an option.
You can do that!
Alright, fine. Whatever.
I'm fine!
It's fine!
We're fine!
Everything's fine!
EVERYTHING'S FINE!
Everything looks about the same.
Got to admit it looks about the same.
Looks...somehow scarier than the first time because I'm n-okay I'm not invincible,
I could lose Big Box Barry at any...
I'd best save.
I gotta fuckin' save.
I could lose Big Box Barry, literally any second.
Imma use my sonar too.
Oh, that thumping and gurgling.
That's the music of the deep, BABY.
Ya! Imma play that at MY WEDDING~
AHH!
*sighs*
If you're wondering, no
I'm not doing okay *laughs* I, ah, I am less than okay.
OH, BOY.
I am so not okay.
I am the EVERYTHING but the OKAY.
But I'm gonna be fine.
(No he's not)
And yes, if you're wondering,
YES, I'M A LITTLE BITCH BABY.
I KNOW THIS.
I'M AWARE OF THIS FACT.
I am PERFECTLY aware of my bitch nature.
It's just I can't-
fathom the idea of being down here
for the REALZIEZZZ
'CAUSE IT'S FILLED WITH DEATH!!!!
(Jesus Mark your face)
Anyway,
now that I've done all that and I've properly said-
that's a Warper warping in right there and then, okay.
Does it see me? Probably. Okay, but nothing it can do when I'm in here so...
fuck on you and
no fuck on me.
I absolutely hate going down this trench,
'cause its ju- *laughs* -st death.
It's just a passageway for death.
It leads you nowhere.
It only goes to the place where you should not go
AND FUUUUUUUCK
those Aliens for thinking that it
was a GOOD idea to build their
"special base"
sPEciSl bASe
down here.
I don't care if the Sea Emperor actually did live down here.
I don't give a flying fuuck.
It is dumb
and they are DUMB
AND I HATE THEM.
Just wanted to clear that to the world.
(PAPI!!!!)
Thunk....sorry.
Don't suck on my butt.
This place is a madhouse and it makes no goddamn-
I don't know what the FUCK THAT WAS.
OH GOD NO!!
Ohhh noo
OHHHHHHH NOOOOO
YOU'RE SCARY NOW!!!!!
Oh, you were moderately scary before
and now you're terrifying.
Oh, where are you?
I don't see him.
I don't like that I don't see him.
Oh, I don't know where he is
Eee...
OH HI!
Okay. Alright. Okay
You just stay...
Do whatever you gotta do to  make yourself feel better about yourself, man. I'm not gonna judge you.
Just-
I know that the entrance down into the depths is around this castle
I just gotta remember exactly where, and I think...
Oh,
just so long as I don't HONK on my HORN.
I think I'll be okay, I just gotta find,
where the drop off is-
Is it over here? Seems like it might be.
Jgheeee...
Okay! I think this is it.
Oh, HI!
Fuck off with you. Goddamn it, don't drain my power.
I'm gonna wait till I get a little deeper to deal with that BULLSHIT!!
*SIGH*
That's a tight squeeze right there *laughs* I don't-ah, man...
Did I come this way before? I can't remember.
Maybe I did.
'Cause I remember trying to squeeze Big Box Barry through here and I don't think
it worked out too well for me.
Alright, Barry, suck-suck it in.
Ahhh...
Hiii...
Heh
Hello
Oh
Ehh
Eh hee hee
Eh HEE HEE
EHH HEE
EHHH HEEE *quick save* EHHH HEEE
UGHHHHHHHEEHEHH
UGHEEHHHHEHHEHEHHEHEHHEHHE
Eh AHAHAHHA
Alright...
All I'm gonna do, is I'm gonna get-
Imma get down-wooohh
Why'd that guy just explode?! Why'd that guy just explode?!
I just gotta fucking get down there.
I'm gonna build ONE base
I'm gonna build a fuckin'-
I'm gonna build a fucking base. That's all I'm gonna do.
I know th-I know the castle's right there. I know that research laboratory whatever-the-fuck-alien bullshit it is.
I KNOW THAT! But what I set out to do...as-AS A PERSONAL GOAL...
FOR ME!! AND ME ALONE!!!!
Ah fuckin' no, you don't.
Was to build a GODDAMN BASSSSSEEEE down here
AND IF IT'S THE LAST GOD DAMN THING I DO
WHICH I HAVE A FUNNY FEELING IT WILL BE THE LAST THING I DO
I'm gonna build it right in that bosom nook.
EHHHHH
I would build it by the castle, but I don't want to go by-
I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING!!!
AHAHAHAH
Okay, I think we're fine.
I think we're alright.
Oh my god, there's so many Warpers.
Why are there so many Warping assholes?
Whoa, what is that?
Oh that's-that's the kyanite, I think.
Okay, but I think...I thinky thunk-
I think I thunk a thunk a lunk-
That I can build a base riiight in here by this kyanite.
That'll be good to look at upon
Yeah, I always prioritize a good view whenever I build my stupid base
wherever the fuck I decide to plant it.
I'm just gonna do what I came to do BECAUSE THAT'S ALL I WANTED TO DO
*Old Man Markiplier* WAS BUILD A GODDAMN BASE
AND I ONLY NEED TO DO THAT EXCEPT I NEED SOME QUARTZ TO BE ABLE TO GET INTO IT
BECAUSE I NEED TO BE ABLE TO BUILD A HATCH
and I don't if I have enough of that.
Fuuuudddge...
Ohhh shiit.
Ahhh, I need glass. Do I have pre-made glass somewhere in here?
Uh, I don't know if I do?
YES I DO.
OHH!! I have everything. Okay.
So, I have that. That's good.
Pfffff
This is gonna be a bad-
this is a bad idea. This is a bad-
this is a fucking bad idea.
This is a goddamn bad idea.
This is fuckin' worst idea I've ever had.
Here we go. EHHHHHH gonna do it anyway.
Oh, right here. This is a good nook.
Oh hi, rays.
Oh, that's a great view, right there.
Ooh, it burns good down here.
THE FUCK? OH, I FORGOT THE WARPER WAS GONNA BE DOWN HERE.
OHH, YOU'RE SUCH A PIECE OF SHIT.
YOU'RE SUCH A PIECE OF SHIT!!
FUCK YOU!! YOU AIN'T GONNA STOP ME!!!!!
I got THIS!!
Oh, just build-
JUST BUILD-
JUST FUCKING BUILD THE THING-WAHHHHHH!!
JUST FUCKING BUILD IT!!!!
FUCKING DO IT!!
OH MY GOD!!!!!!!!!!!
NO, YOU'RE NOT GONNA STOP ME!!!!!!!
YOU'RE NOT GONNA STOP ME!!!!!!!!
AH AH AH AH AH-
GET IN!!!!
AH FUCK!!!!
*sigh of relief*
AHHHHHHHHHHH
I DID IT!!!!
OHHHH I DID IT!!
It doesn't have any power.
Hahe
I need like a thermal generator for it.
AHHH
Did I bring any magnetite?
I have no idea.
I didn't bring any lube
(Sounds like a personal problem)
Ah, fuck.
Oh, god
Ugh...
Oh, fuck, I didn't bring any lube.
(XD)
I know there's no oxygen in here. I'm just getting a breather before I go out there again.
Me! I'm getting a breather.
Fuck.
Oh my god.
What's in this thing?
What kind of resources can I expect down here?
Diamond! Great.
That's gonna help me.
Is that lube?
Can I lube up a diamond?
(Wtf was his hand doing?)
Just LUBE up with diamonds all over me.
Oww...
It burns real good down here.
Fuck all of this
and fuck all of you.
(I'm hurt)
OKAY!
I did it.
I built a base and I forgot everything
I don't care!
Ahhh...
Fuck me.
Everything about that was awful.
SO
We have a base,
which means
it's not-it's not a real base because it's doesn't have power
but, you know what, I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna split hairs here,
I've got something with a hatch!
And that's all that I really wanted so,
I'm just gonna park this guy,
right here
where you assholes can stop being assholes,
down grade to dick holes
and I can end this episode.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching.
I know that I'm curently being drained of power and everything is bad but
WE'RE ALIVE! And we're down here.
So, in the next episode, I'm going in that castle and I'm gonna feel-
I'm gonna feel? I'm gonna see the f-find the cure for the Carar virus and then
Imma get out of here...
Hopefully.
Maybe?
I don't know.
We'll see.
But either way,
thank you everybody so much for watching.
Let me know how I'm doing in the comments below.
And as always
I will see you....
In the next video
Buh-bye *waves*
Alright since I did this all by my self, Hi the names Helicoprion (Also some correction here and editing there by me, Adam-Eve, and one other anonymous)
Just so you know, this took a total of 5 hours to do so your welcome
Hope these are good (They did very good)
Lots of love from your fan:
Helicoprion!!!